le président russe s'est lancé dans une
rhétorique escalatatoire
en décrétant la mobilisation partielle
de la population russe une population
qui a l'évidence ne le soutient plus le
nombre de Russes qui fuient en Géorgie à
doubler depuis vendredi 10 000
d'entrepasses chaque jour la frontière
pour échapper à la mobilisation générale
décrétée par Vladimir Poutine pour
combattre en Ukraine les bouchons sont
tels qu'il y a 48 heures d'attente pour
entrer dans le pays voici les quatre
zones ukrainiennes en passent d'être
annexées par Moscou à l'est les régions
séparatistes de l'ougand ce qui est
donnés ce qui constitue le don-basse au
sud celle sous occupations russes de
zapporijah et Kerson en annonçant
l'organisation de
simulacre de référendum dans les régions
occupées si la Russie procède à
l'organisation de ces référendum
illégaux et bien il y aura des sanctions
dans le cadre de cette opération
spéciale et du déroulement des
référendums dans le don-basse
le sauvetage de ces populations
tout ces territoires
est au centre de l'attention de notre
société et de notre pays résultat
provisoire des référendums devraient
être annoncés au plus tôt ce soir si le
will emporte ce qui est plus que
probable le Parlement russe vautra un
traité formalisant l'intégration des
quatre régions à son territoire ancien
président russe Mitry Medvedev que
voyait à l'écran assure d'ailleurs que
Moscou défendra ses territoires coûte
que coûte je vais le répéter encore une
fois pour les oreilles sourdes je le
cite évidemment la Russie a le droit
d'utiliser des armes nucléaires si
nécessaire
quand elle teste un système de
monte-escalier pour les personnes à
mobilité réduite il n'en fallait pas
plus pour que les internautes se
déchaînent il y a les blagues sur son
mauvais score à la présidentielle et le
non remboursement de ses frais de
campagne le financement de la campagne
présidentielle de Valérie Pécresse dans
le viseur de la justice le parquet de
Paris a ouvert une enquête préliminaire
pour détournement de fonds publics
l'information judiciaire aurait été
déclenchée le signalement au printemps
de Julien Baillot alors secrétaire
national d'Europe Écologie Les Verts
debout la séquence est largement
détournée Valérie Pécresse dans l'espace
ou dans le jeu Tetris elle rejoint aussi
les autres mêmes qui ont amusé le web
ces dernières semaines le taux de
réplication que l'on évalue toutes les
semaines et passer de 0,9 à un 7 à 1,37
la semaine dernière j'attends
aujourd'hui les chiffres de la semaine
de la semaine précédente donc ça vous
dites il a recirculation du virus donc
il y a remobilisation bien entendu sur
les murs de la mairie des affiches
indiquent que les services informatiques
ont été touchés par une cyberattaque
aucun document d'identité ne peut être
délivré jusqu'à nouvel ordre donc nous
allons vers une campagne de vaccination
à partir de cet automne à partir même
pour être exact du 3 octobre où nous
aurons à disposition là aussi les
nouveaux vaccins c'est hier en début
d'après-midi que ces serveurs de la
ville sont touchés par un logiciel
malveillant une cyber offensive éclair
10 attaques par seconde selon la mairie
très vite les sites de la communauté de
communes et de la ville deviennent
indisponible pour tous les utilisateurs
je pense qu'il est temps de siffler la
fin de la récréation on ne joue pas avec
nos institutions
la libération de la parole de la femme
oui même au travers des réseaux sociaux
peu à peu se dessine des reliefs des
roches et des cratères jusqu'à la
coupure du signal vidéo qui signifie que
l'Impact a bien eu lieu on est en train
là de créer une justice de droit privé
qui n'a strictement aucun sens la
voiture de police dans laquelle cette
femme menottait et conduite et située
sur un passage à niveau garé en plein
passage à niveau et au bout de quelques
secondes vous allez le voir sur cette
image prise par des télescopes géants on
voit le souffle de l'impact sur
l'astéroïde d'immorphoses vous allez
voir ça va très très vite qui arrive à
toute vitesse et qui percute donc deux
plein fouet ce véhicule dans lequel se
trouve la dite jeune fille fort
heureusement la jeune femme âgée de 20
ans s'en est sorti quasiment indemnes en
attendant les résultats une chose est
sûre pour les scientifiques aucun
astéroïde connu ne menace notre planète
pour les 100 prochaines années